we can't talk beauty babies without
mentioning the Royal that's right and as
you know Captain Fraser has been
tracking the proud parents to be hairy
and make it all over Sydney and now he
takes us inside fascination of being
born into royalty royal babies get used
to official photo ops from the moment
they are born Prince William made his
public debut right after birth as did
Harry whose real name is Prince Henry
Charles Albert aided the too cheeky
princes seemed very comfortable in front
of cameras for a BBC documentary Harry
and William gave play-by-play as they
watched rare home movies of their
younger days I must have a living - this
was an infant Harry at his christening
it's hot so if you're a boy or a girl a
night to dress
thank you for I don't have normally
happens at this stage of your life you
see the moment it's great in blue the
dress that onion seems it's a royal
family tradition to ham it up as their
parents rolled a movie camera here is
the 92 year old Queen as a baby the
curly haired blonde was born Princess
Elizabeth her future husband Prince
Philip was also a towheaded tyke
Prince Charles drove a fancy custom ride
when he was a little one and recognized
these royal Rugrats frolicking and
leaves it's the Queen's sons princes
Andrew and Edward both baby Megan and
tiny Harry were cute as buttons so we
had some fun with computer imagery
here's a possible look at their bundle
of joy to be so until the arrival next
spring were happy looking at cute baby
shots of his or her royal older cousins
[Music]
[Applause]